hey guys so seemingly as ever these days
I have been really busy I actually have
a lot to talk about in a vlog which is
great because that means it won't
hopefully be too boring for you so since
we last boat the major thing which has
happened is that I went off to Vienna on
a conference now I did three videos on
that if you sell how much to miss those
I'll include a link to a playlist of
them in the description below it was an
amazing experience and frankly it kind
of has been a nice kind of round off to
my my first year as a PhD student
because it almost to me feels like I
kind of came of age academically and I
could sit in a specialist conference and
not say she didn't actually understand
what was going on and that also ties in
with the fact that my first year review
was doing quite recently and admittedly
it hasn't active in 12 months since I
started my PhD is actually been about
eight but the department wants you to
summarize what you've done within the
first year in inverted commas of your
PhD write stuff in a document and then
you have to defend it in a mini Viper
which for me hasn't happened yet
this document involved several things
and first of all it was the research
which you have done so far the research
which you are going to do now that
particular point it was an issue of
contention for me and my supervisor for
a while because I wasn't really given a
very specific research title up until
quite recently what I have now is a very
definite research question which I will
talk about a little bit later which I'm
actually incredibly excited to be
getting on with in addition to that work
stuff there was also a small literature
review a couple of thousand words of the
specialist literature relating to your
research question and that fortunately
was pre-written but it did have to be
altered slightly because even in the
short space of time between me writing
that literature of you and that on my
understanding has developed quite
significantly and I look back and
realize there's a pretty glaring errors
like I guess a lot of phd's I I kind of
I have what's called impostor syndrome
in a sense that I feel that I don't
deserve to be here I don't desert within
this PhD and doing this kind of review
this technical review really makes you
realize that you have come an awful long
way and not very long at all and in
addition to those scientific questions
there was also questions based on your
training your development because here
in Exeter they're very keen on you not
just working towards publications which
are ultimately the hard currency of
academia they're also really keen on you
developing and training
for me that's meant going to career
sessions which has been general career
sessions and also a Makura session on
doctoral students people with PhDs in
the arts because ultimately what I do
with this for YouTube stuff is really
kind of an arty type thing certainly
compared to the more hardcore technical
stuff and so you know I've kind of been
training on two forks I've got the
technical stuff on one side they've also
got this issue stuff on another and I
feel like it's really important to
develop both and so fortunately if
there's the department and my supervisor
my supervisor is soaking in fact on me
doing social media more generally than
YouTube that he's asked me to give us a
seminar in the department about academic
use of social media so in a few minutes
time I'm gonna have to stand up in front
of the it's technically the college of
engineering mathematics and physical
sciences so it's kind of all the hard
science you type stuff on in the
university and talk to them about the
fact I talk to a camera in West bed time
but equally tweet and use Facebook so
that's a little bit daunting equally if
you if anybody watching is an academic
or has an interest in following
academics on social media then please to
leave in the comments what you think I
should talk about you know how do
academics use social media most
effectively and that could be new grass
Tyson or Brian Cox or it could just be
somebody if you are an academic in your
field that would be really very useful
to me actually if nothing else to say in
my talk about social media that I use
social media to write this talk I
mentioned before about my particular
research question and you know that's
kind of why I'm here so I better talk
about it so very generally my research
is in the dynamical coupling of the
stratosphere in the troposphere and if
you want a background on this I've
already did a talk in Oxford which I
filmed and there'll be a link available
on the screen and in the description if
you want to check that out but what that
may basically means is the middle
atmosphere in the lower atmosphere how
the middle atmosphere forces what
happens in terms of weather and more
longer-term phenomena in the lower
atmosphere and that was sort of what I
was working on for several months and
then I sat down with my supervisor and
my tube supervisors actually I should
mention I do you have to and we fleshed
out a plan for very specifically what
I'm going to do my main supervisor
professor Mark Baldwin has this theory
that when you when you when you split
the atmosphere into two
layers the let's best just consider the
strategy in the troposphere the
stratosphere on top of the troposphere
below and the boundary between is called
atropos
now my supervisor has this theory that
if you consider the polar region say
north of 65 degrees north as one entity
then the height of that boundary between
the troposphere and the stratosphere the
middle in our atmosphere is determined
by the amount of air the the literal
mass of air which moves into the polar
stratosphere and effectively what it
does is it acts as a pump or a piston
and when you add an anomalously large
amount of mass to the polar regions
stratosphere it depresses that boundary
it forces it down and that produces
pressure and temperature anomalies over
the north pop what my PhD is doing is
going to be looking at really simple
dynamical models literally box models
saying here is the non polar atmosphere
here is the polar atmosphere there's an
upper bit and a lower bit and that's as
complicated as the first model will be
and looking at if we put a certain
latter mass into the polar stratosphere
what kind of effect will that have on
the polar troposphere and then building
up those models in terms of complexity
so they start out as being analytical
working out with pen and paper and
they're moving more into down to
numerical models which I will run on
first of all my computer when they're
very simple and later the cluster which
we have here next to and it's actually
quite cool because this means that the
climate model which I talked about in my
eg videos and I think a few videos
previously Ashley comes becomes useful
now because I have experience of writing
simple numerical models and running them
so it's great because I get to turn a
hobby into my job which I suppose the
whole PhD kind of is my other job though
as I talked about in sort of training
aspect has been this YouTube stuff and
in addition to doing my own channel in
the past I set up a YouTube channel for
my college in Oxford's and Peters and I
was recently contacted by the college
and they have hired me literally hired
me to make more videos for the college
and so last week I went back to Oxford
for several days and I did a whole week
of shooting so I shot interviews with
people from all over the college I shot
college sports I shot with some music in
the college including in the chapel
choir
and try to capture the spirit of the
college while students are still there
because term is about to finish I also
met up with the Ox loggers for lunch and
this is what they have but these two
days this year so hopefully I'm gonna be
back on next year and zani it looks like
you're going to be taking over my right
[Music]
now those videos are gonna be out in
September starting in September then
released every month but I already
released one in case you didn't see it I
interviewed my friend Ryan Kemp who was
basically the official version of me
within college and as far as I'm
concerned he's his the student expert on
access to Oxford there's a link on
screen right now if you'd like to check
that video out and also a link in the
description one of the other interesting
things which I did was sit down and film
one of my other friends and I McCrory
who was when she was at Oxford the
University Poetry Society president and
she is a fantastically talented young
poet actually featured in one of my ox
blogs and with her permission I'm
hopefully gonna upload one of her
original works to this channel so stay
tuned for that in about week or so the
really exciting thing about the whole
project is the fact that the college
hired me now that might sound quite
shallow but they didn't pay me and money
what they did was they paid me in kit so
this video is wonderfully lit right now
because they bought me some soft boxes
there's one there and there's one back
there which I would be able to show you
my second camera which is a GoPro they
bought me a bloody GoPro I'm so sorry
I'm such a techie for the longest time
when I've been making videos I have tech
Envy I look at other people's cameras
and so have I them up and wonder if I
could steal them
not really and so to actually have some
really really cool kit it's fantastic
I'm really really grateful for the
college to give me this opportunity to
make the videos which I really do want
to do because
I love my colleagues and it's been such
a privilege to have gone to it and it's
been such a massive influence on my life
I want to see it thrive now that I've
got a few pieces of extra kit hopefully
I'm going to be doing a kind of tour
around Exeter because I'd love you to
see this place because I think it is
incredibly pretty it's a big selling
point of this university that you get to
go to a campus and have it be as lovely
as it is I realized that for a long time
I have talked about doing a string
theory video and doing a few some more
scientific videos they are coming I
promise I'm gonna sit down later today
or tomorrow and write the script for
this string theory video which I have
been taking over my head for quite some
time and that is going to be done within
the next couple of weeks I swear on my
life now if you excuse me because today
is the steam summer sale I bought skyrim
because it was about to pound 50 so I'm
actually probably not gonna make any
more videos about my PhD because I'm
probably just gonna sit here for a
couple of weeks straight and pretend
that I live in the elderscrolls I'll be
seeing you around hopefully quite soon
for some more videos cheers for watching
guys